les agriculteurs sont confrontés depuis
longtemps à la réalité des maladies
fongiques des champignons qui s'attaque
aux plantes qui peuvent causer de
lourdes pertes aux champs mais depuis
quelques années les champignons font des
victimes au delà du règne végétal
les dernières en lice sont les
amphibiens
les amphibiens existe depuis plus de 350
millions d'années ils ont côtoyé les
dinosaures et survécu à quatre
extinction de masse
pourtant ils vivent actuellement un
déclin mondial alarmant c'est la classe
animale la plus menacée avec près d'un
tiers des espèces dites en danger des
dizaines ont déjà disparu la cause
principale la perte d'habitat et depuis
quelques années une nouvelle menace
s'ajoute celle d'un champignon tueur
d'amphibiens le battre à coke yttrium
dendrobatidis le bd elle était découvert
dans en amérique centrale puis ensuite
aux états unis à la fin des années 90 ce
qui était vraiment la prise de
conscience par le monde scientifique
c'est qu'on avait cette épidémie qui se
propage et sur toute la planète avec des
mortalités massives de centaines
d'individus au sein de populations qui
ont retrouvé le ventre en l'air
le champignon est originaire d'asie il
s'est propagé sur tous les continents où
l'on trouve des amphibiens il engendre
une maladie appelée quitterie diomi
cause les quitterait ne s'attaque aux
cellules de l'épiderme donc aux cellules
de la peau des amphibiens et c'est un
organe qui est très fragile chez les
amphibiens parce qu'il leur permet de
respirer et ils mangent la kératine que
ces cellules produisent donc ça entraîne
une hyper kératinisation c'est à dire
que les cellules se met à produire de
plus en plus de kératine en réponse à
l'infection et la couche de kératine
épaissi sur la peau et il n'ya plus
d'échangé possible donc les amphibiens
meurent parce qu'ils ne peuvent plus
respirer
[Musique]
le vétérinaire stéphane lehr surveille
les causes de mortalité des animaux
sauvages au canada en 2021 il a reçu
pour la première fois une grenouille
morte d'une infection aux bd
[Musique]
4 et 9 qui a été soumis à pour dernière
fait c'est une relève pour grillon
boréale et on a pu voir une copie qui
avaient des visions cataractes est
restée l'infection
on peut voir les petits champignons tarn
labiles psl de faire
un traitement existent pour les animaux
en captivité c'est un banc antifongique
pour grenouille mais il est
difficilement adaptables au milieu
naturel
marin
peut pas reconnu tu pars à fécamp
pouvait
battre
pour sauver les espèces les plus
menacées par le bde l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature a mis sur pied près de 300
projets de reproduction d'amphibiens en
captivité comme ici au biodôme de
montréal
[Musique]
en 2017 la za nous a invités à
participer au projet de la grenouille
doré prodigue ou d'une femme ça c'est
l'espèce interrompu cette équipe
une des journaux et où les grenouilles
sont belles mais bon elle est
particulièrement belle la grenouille
doré est vénéré au panama c'est un
emblème national en captivité sa
reproduction est difficile en 2019 on a
eu une première faute et depuis on a eu
cette pente 2 et à plusieurs
institutions qui le font aussi donc on
main st entre nous une population
captive d'assurance dans l'espoir que
éventuellement quand on sait comment on
peut aider les amphibiens combattre de
quitterie on pourrait les relancer à
nouveau dans leur environnement le
risque c'est qu'on connaît pas quelle
est leur susceptibilité et s'il si on
n'a pas éliminé les champignons de
l'endroit où on va les remettre
finalement on les condamne avant de les
remettre dans la nature
[Musique]
pour midi j'avais prévu de mélanger les
échantillons qui viennent de los tres et
de spectral clip où la probabilité de
détecter diminue un peu ou pas du tout
non pas du tout faute de pouvoir
éliminer le champignon de
l'environnement
la doctorante léa fieschi méric compte
sur les défenses naturelles de certains
amphibiens
au canada il ya un exemple très
intéressant c'est celui de la salamandre
cendres est donc une petite espèce de
salamandre locale qui a dans son micro
blog cutanées des bactéries qui lui
permettent de se défendre contre le
champignon midi
la doctorante regarde la composition du
microbiome de la peau des salamandres et
des tritons du parc algonquin en ontario
et comme ce bactéries viennent souvent
de l'environnement elle regarde aussi
l'effet de la captivité sur ses défenses
naturelles ce qui nous semble le plus
important c'est de garder un microbiome
riches parce que au plus on a de
bactéries différentes dans son nid
chromium os plus on a des chances
d'avoir une bactéries protectrices
[Musique]
ça serait cool si je trouvais des oeufs
on dit
[Musique]
voilà un oeuf jeu les ratés mais est
probable par contre elle est pas certain
faut bien comprendre que les animaux
qu'on met en captivité et c'est vrai
pour les éléphants les pingouins et les
grenouilles c'est finalement ils vivent
un peu dans une bulle ils sont nourris
tous les jours ils ont des cages qui
sont très propres et 7,7 propreté aussi
induit à la disparition de bactéries qui
pourraient leur être favorable et dans
ces cas là la bio augmentation
l'augmentation de leurs microbiome de la
richesse de leurs microbiome par l'ajout
de bactéries protectrices par exemple ça
peut être une solution qui sera
envisageable on n'en est pas du tout
encore là parce que ça pose d'autres
problèmes éthiques
[Musique]
le bd est présent dans cinq provinces et
un territoire au canada au québec il a
même été retrouvés dans des grenouilles
échantillonnés dans les années 60
[Musique]
ou à notre avis il ne ferme pas être
fait avec les calendriers mortalité très
bas donc il semblerait qu ici les
animaux ont réussi à cauet évolué avec
ces maladies ça semble pas conduire au
des claques on a observé dans d'autres
pays
la mycose engendrés par le bde aurait
anéanti des centaines d'espèces de
grenouilles et depuis 2013 une nouvelle
menace plane sur l'amérique du nord le
champignon battre à coke yttrium
salamandre ivoire ans découverts aux
pays-bas cette fois après avoir décimé
96 % d'une population de salamandre de
feu en seulement trois ans
donc on a un deuxième champignons qui
nous arrive vous qui va nous arriver
d'europe la question c'est vraiment pas
est ce qu'il va arriver c'est plutôt
quand il va arriver notre rôle c'est
vraiment de l'anticiper une étude qui a
été faite sur les espèces locales
notamment a montré que 65 espèces qui
ont été testées elles étaient toutes
susceptibles de mourir en quelques jours
les
cahiers de le minimiser les risques avec
en 2017 le gouvernement canadien a
modifié son règlement sur le commerce
des espèces animales et végétales
sauvages pour limiter l'importation de
salamandre
énormément de trafic d'animaux est
notamment de grenouilles vous avez
sûrement vu des grenouilles de toutes
les couleurs qui donnent d'amazonie et
qui malheureusement sont récupérées dans
leurs habitats sauvages et revendus aux
quatre coins de la planète sont qu' il
ya évidemment de tests qu'ils soient
faits pour savoir si les animaux sont
malades pas malade
on compte environ 8400 espèces
d'amphibiens dans le monde et les
menaces sont multiples comme la
pollution les changements climatiques la
sur exploitation commerciale la
destruction d'habitats autant de
facteurs qui influencent la virulence
des champignons
on peut par afrique n'a senti craquer à
fond alors le thème imitable pu faire et
il pourrait développer on peut appeler
appelé les factions secondaire de bd et
et hambourg et mais il faut savoir qu'il
ya à peu près autour de 680 espèce de
salamandre connu il y en a la moitié qui
se retrouvent en amérique du nord ça
veut dire qu'on peut vraiment avoir une
catastrophe à l'échelle planétaire pour
perdre et la moitié de la diversité des
salamandres de la planète
on devrait s'inquiéter du fait que les
amphibiens sont largement déclin on
pourrait dire que c'est les canari dans
une mine de charbon les premiers qui
vont être affectés par des perturbateurs
leur déclin nous indiquent qu'il ya des
problèmes dans l'environnement qui vont
éventuellement affecter d'autres espèces
et nous inclus